welcome back so we're talking about
machine learning or building models from
data models that improve with data and
now I want to tell you a little bit more
about some of the aspects we want these
models to have so how are we gonna use
these machine learning models and what
are the properties that distinguish a
good model from a bad model so I'm going
to talk about what we want and this is a
pretty nuanced and subtle set of
features that we want our machine
learning models to have and so I'm just
going to talk you through some of these
issues I'm going to start kind of a
little vague to begin with what we
really want is our models to be useful
in the future whatever that means so we
want them to be useful in the future and
there's different different ways that
models can be useful it depends on what
your questions are and what you're going
to use them for oftentimes remember our
models are built on training data so
this is data that I have right now and
what I hope is that the data I have
right now is representative of what I'm
going to see in the future how I'm going
to use the model in the future I hope
that there's things I can learn now that
will be useful in the future I will talk
more about about what this means in a
minute and so so for example if I have a
bunch of pictures of cats and dogs
labeled cat cat dog and cat dog and I
learn what are the features of a cat and
a dog then in the future what I might
want is to have new pictures of either
cats or dogs and have this machine
learning model tell me is that a cat or
a dog and so two really important
aspects of any model really these are
two critical aspects of models are being
accurate and fast accurate and efficient
so fast or efficient and this is usually
a balance usually you can get more
accurate but slower models or faster but
less accurate and that's actually one of
the reasons people really like machine
learning in practice is because it looks
like in a lot of applications you can
get kind of fast and accurate
models and so machine learning is often
used in applications where you need an
answer in an automated or fast way where
you can't just ship off the question to
an expert human okay so when Google or
Facebook or trying to label images they
can't afford to send all those images to
an expert human have them label them and
then send them back to you this has to
be an automatic process I think about
self-driving cars if my self-driving car
has something move across its field of
view it has to very rapidly decide and
accurately decide was that a human
running into the field of view is that a
child on a bike or a deer and those are
our decisions that you can't wait around
for and you need accurate decisions and
you hope that you can make those
decisions based on the models you've
trained from your data ok and some
models some things you'll use machine
learning for are easier for the past
data to work in the future ok so that
example of cats and dogs I think is
pretty a pretty simple example where if
I have a big enough database of cats and
dogs and I have them labeled then
probably I can build a useful model that
will tell me in the future if an image
is a cat or a dog now there are some
things that are much more tricky to
model to have future predictions based
on present data and those situations the
issue is called generalize abilities so
we want our model to generalize not just
from data in the past we want it to
sometimes generalize to entirely new
scenarios we might not have seen before
but to have similar rules to the data in
the past and I'll talk a little bit more
about this so we want our models to be
generalizable and I'm putting this in
red and I'm going to put a star next to
it because this is actually very
important and it's also very challenging
so this is kind of an open problem in
machine learning research is building
models that are in fact very
generalizable to new new things that I
haven't necessarily seen before and I
want to give a very concrete and
tangible example of this Newton's second
law F equals MA is what I mean by a
generalized
model this is like the ultimate
generalizable model if I know F equals
MA if I if I study a system over here if
I study an apple falling and I learned
that F equals MA over here I can use Fe
equals MA pretty much on any mechanical
system okay so I can take what I learned
from the Apple falling or what Newton
learned from the Apple falling and I can
use that to understand how the planets
move and I can design you know space
mission design trajectories of rockets
to get to the moon so F equals MA is the
kind of model that is generalizable
where we can take what we learned over
here and use it for example to land
people on the moon which is which is
really remarkable
we're not even nearly there in machine
learning but there are big efforts
underway pushes to build machine
learning models that are more
generalizable than they are now and some
some architectures are better at
generalizing than other architectures
another really important aspect that I
want my machine learning models to be
able to have is what we call
interpretability so I want to be able to
interpret my model another way of saying
this and it's not exactly the same thing
but it's close is explainable I want to
be able to interpret or explain what my
algorithm is doing again read with a
star very important very difficult and
so as machine learning algorithms are
becoming more ubiquitous in society for
you know speech recognition but
increasingly for things like
self-driving cars and things where human
lives are at stake there's this
increasing sentiment that we deserve or
have a right to explainable machine
learning to be able to have an
explanation for how that algorithm made
that decision for better or worse that's
a huge huge area of machine learning
that again hundreds of people are
working on on making these these systems
more generalizable and explainable and
as we start to to use machine learning
more for an engineering and industrial
applications things like self-driving
cars there's also this idea that I might
need to certify my model
I need to certify or guarantee that my
model is going to work the way I expect
it to under certain certain conditions
and that's something again you can do
with physics pace models you can kind of
manage the uncertainty of what you can't
model and what you can model and certify
and guarantee these and that's also
something that we are very much working
towards in machine learning so we want
them to be useful oftentimes that just
means fast and accurate you know if I
trained a model to tell cats and dogs
apart I want to be able to do that
quickly in the future but increasingly
for these more kind of safety critical
applications we want our models to be
able to generalize we want to be able to
explain what the algorithm is doing and
we want to be able to certify and
guarantee you that these models are in
fact going to be kind of bound ibly or
provably close to the real world in in
use ok so this is some of the some of
the features and and the texture of what
we want our machine learning algorithms
to do thank you